-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight
and, now, we are going
to get to the news.
President Biden is set tomorrow
to pardon the annual
White House turkey
and Steve Bannon's got an idea
just crazy enough to work.
[ Laughter and applause ]
After test driving
an electric Hummer pickup truck
in Michigan yesterday,
President Biden said,
"This sucker's something else."
Okay, but, don't give him one.
I mean, the last thing
anyone needs is
a 78-year-old man driving a car
that you can't hear coming.
[ Laughter ]
After Texas Senator Ted Cruz
accused Republican
Congresswoman Liz Cheney,
in a recent interview, of having
Trump Derangement Syndrome,
Cheney tweeted,
"Trump broke Ted Cruz."
Yeah, but that's like breaking
an IKEA bookshelf.
It was about to go, anyway.
[ Laughter ]
"You put books on it?!
Ohh!
You can't put books on it!"
[ Laughter ]
Fox Chairman Rupert Murdoch
reportedly told News Corp's
shareholders -- stockholders --
Excuse me.
Shareholders, stockholders --
I think it's the same.
What do you want to go with,
Baze?
-Share.
-I think stock's funnier.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Stockholders at a recent meeting
that former President Trump
"needs to move on"
from the 2021 election.
Okay, but you, first.
[ Laughter ]
Probably hurt the joke,
doing that little size trip,
but I got my Baze burn in.
[ Laughter ]
The NFL announced yesterday
that it will heighten
its coronavirus protocols amid
rising cases across the country.
Starting this weekend,
Aaron Rodgers will be forced
to attend the huddle via Zoom.
[ Laughter and applause ]
New York's MTA announced
yesterday that it has approved
the purchase
of 60 fully electric buses,
which cost about $1 million each
and have a top speed of
we'll never know.
[ Laughter ]
The discount department store
chain T.J.Maxx
announced yesterday
that it will increase prices
on some of its upscale brands
and you'll know they're upscale
because they're the ones not
on the floor.
[ Laughter and applause ]
New York Jets quarterback
Joe Flacco announced
at a press conference yesterday
that he is not vaccinated
against the coronavirus
and said that he
"has his reasons."
I mean, he's a backup
quarterback on the Jets.
I assume his reason is
that he's ready to die.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, New York Jets
quarterback Joe Flacco announced
he's not vaccinated
against the coronavirus,
but don't worry
about his teammates.
It's rare for the Jets
to catch anything.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
Yeah, why not?
Why not? Yeah.
Enjoy yourselves.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, tomorrow is
National Play Monopoly Day,
which means this Saturday is
National Finish Monopoly Day.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, that was a monologue!